bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
au programme de cette édition le
festival orphet théâre et Handicap fait
ses 10 ans Michel Renault directeur
artistique nous parle de la
programmation tout mêl le festival de
musique éclectique de mole démarre le 19
septembre pour 3 jours de festivité
lisab béanjon et Vincent amoureux nous
donne tous les détails Nicolas Gervet
notre chroniqueur a rencontré les
artistes du spectacle Bobby la pointe
repiqué qui se donnera au scarabé le 28
septembre chaque semaine le 7e 7e art
est mise à l'honneur dans notre
chronique Cinéfil Gael Pinot responsable
du cinéma Le grenieracel à trappe nous
livre son coup de cœur
mais pour démarrer présentation de nos
invités lisabéanjon Vincent amoureux
bonsoir à tous les deux donc vous êtes
membres de l'association tout mêlé vous
allez nous parler du festival qui porte
le même nom tout mêlé et qui a lieu donc
à Mle on en reparle dans quelques
instants mais tout d'abord nous partons
pour un autre festival alors il s'agit
d'un festival qui réunit sur scène
depuis 10 ans maintenant des artistes
professionnels en situation de handicap
mais ce dans un dans dans comment dire
dans l'expression de le du plus beau de
leur talent alors Michel Reno bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur artistique de ce
festival alors je vous propose avant de
que vous nous parliez de la
programmation un petit peu plus en
détail qu'on regarde un reportage qui
nous donnera justement une vue
d'ensemble de ce festival pour ces 10
ans le festival orpé réserve de belles
surprises théâtre et danse sont à
l'honneur mais pas seulement l'édition
2013 et l'occasion d'ouvrir la scène à
de nouveaux champs d'expression tels que
la comédie musicale ou encore l'opéra en
langue des ces une première en France
orpé œuvre à la promotion du handicap
sous toutes ses formes et cette année
donne un nouvel élan à son projet ce
rendez-vous annuel jusqu'ici présenté au
Théâtre mont-ancier à Versailles
s'élargit désormais à six espaces en Île
de France pour l'ouverture Frédéric
Zetoun connu du petit écran pour ses
chroniques musicales nous raconte son
histoire une création en avant-première
qui traite avec humour et tendresse du
handicap la 50e bougie sur le gâteau et
le fait d'être nouvellement papa m'ont
donné envie de de dire des choses et
peut-être de transmettre je me suis dit
que j'avais peut-être un petit peu voix
au chapitre un petit peu une petite
fenêtre de tir pour pouvoir parler donc
autantah oui donc j'ai parlé de ma vie
avec l'autodérision comme comme seu et
unique moteur c'est vrai vraiment on a
avec avec François despenou avec qui
j'aiécris ce spectacle en fait on a on a
écrit à 4
tout le tout le livret et les chansons
je les ai écrit tout seul pour les
paroles et j'ai demandé de l'aide à
certains amis compositeurs qui
généreusement je pense à Charles navour
notamment qui nous a fait cadeau de de
deux musiqu et dans ce spectacle ce qui
est donc un spectacle tout
en en partie en gué en musique
en en émotion aussi qui une des rares
voire même sans doute première fois au
monde fort U pour
raconter la réalité de la vie de
fr une vie pas tout à fait comme les
autres que partagent ces artistes
professionnels en situation de handicap
le festival ORP n'a plus à démontrer que
tout est possible le handicap peut
amener à une création artistique
différente car n'est-ce pas seul la
différence qui compte lorsque l'on parle
de
création al mich le festival sa 10e
bougie cette année et également c'est
l'occasion d'explorer un nouveau terrain
d'expression par le biais en
l'occurrence de la comédie musicale qui
a fait l'ouverture du festival hier soir
qu'est-ce qui vous a qu'est-ce qui vous
a donné envie de choisir la création de
de Frédéric Zetoun pour l'ouverture
écoutez d'abord on travaille trois
festivalfit avec Rachel boulanger duumas
et Amandine txier donc on reçoit tout au
long de l'année beaucoup de de
propositions et évidemment on a saisi
cette opportunité de quand on a su que
Frédéric faisait ce spectacle qui a eu
lieu hier d'ailleurs et qui a été un
moment un lancement du festival
extraordinaire parce que effectivement
là il y avait un double un double
discours c'est-à-dire d'abord des vrais
artistes sur scène qui qui nous ont
régalé par leur invention par leur
musique par leur
chançon et par le leur qualités
artistique mais aussi un discours sur
sur en particulier là le handicap
physique et et la vie de Frédéric setoun
est exemplaire à ce niveau-là et le
quotien donc été oui le quotidien les
obstacles les les choses ridicules
ilelle a rendu des hommages assez
appuyés à des gens en particulier
Jacques Martin moi qui m'a beaucoup
touché parce que c'est rare les gens qui
savent reconnaître les gens qui leur ont
ouvert des portes donc c'était c'était
un spectacle très très touchant et que
les gens pourront voir d'ailleurs au
Théâtre du Petit du 22 septembre à y
aller parce que c'est vraiment un un
très très bon moment donc voilà c'est
des rencontres à un moment donné avec
des artistes voilà alors bien bien sûr
la la qualité artistique est pour nous
un un vecteur primordial mais c'est
surtout aussi la la générosité des gens
voilà là on a on a passé une une journée
enfin quelques jours avec eux
extraordinaire quoi c'est des gens très
généreux et et très plein d'humilité par
rapport à ce qu'ils font quoi h HM la
question du handicap n'est pas euh il
est pas question de parler de handicap
mais vraiment de de pouvoir montrer dans
le casre d'une expression artistique
aussi toutes les faisabilités nous ce
qu'on souhaite avec orpé c'est surtout
de de permettre l'expression artistique
alors pour des personnes évidemment qui
souffent d'un handicap c'est un choix
c'est c'est un choix de vie que j'ai
fait moi que Rachel aussi a fait d'une
certaine manière mais voilà c'est c'est
quelque chose on part par contre pas de
la discussion sur leur handicap mais sur
leur capacité à faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire et de le montrer et à
partir de là la question du handicap le
point de vue change totalement
c'està-dire que d'un seul coup on oublie
la difficulté pour se concentrer sur la
qualité de de production des personnes
et à ce moment-là voilà le vivre
ensemble il se fait naturellement alors
justement vous présentez également dans
dans le cadre du festival ORF pour une
première fois en France un opéra carè en
langue des signes oui ça ça c'est une
chance ça c'est une chance parce que ça
c'est une première ça jamais alors
comment les les spectateurs vont vont
assister à cet opéra qu'est-ce qui est
mis en place bah je peux pas tout
révéler parce qu'il y a des petits
secrets techniques mais voilà non mais
il va y avoir plein de plein de choses
qui permettent aux gens de ce sont des
danseurs sourd d'abord voilà sont des
danseurs sourds donc l'expression
corporelle le langage des signes va va
être primordial c'està-dire c'est comme
s'ils chantaient mais ils vont parler
avec leur mains comme font comme font
les les sours évidemment alors il y aura
des des traductions pour les entendants
qui vont être handicapés pour le coup là
ça ça on va inverser un peu le le
problème ça c'est rigolo il y aura des
soutitrage et puis eux ils ont des tas
de systèmes techniques des vibrations du
du plancher enfin voilà voilà parce
qu'en fait les danseurs sourds se repère
aux vibration oui oui voilà donc ils on
ils ont des systèmes vous savez on a eu
des spectacles avec des des personnes
aveugles où ils avaient des trucs de de
décor qui leur permettaiit d'évoluer
sans qu' l'impression voilà donc cha
c'est une des grandes forces de de ce
travail avec les personnes handicapées
c'est l'invention qu'il faut avoir pour
arriver à faire des mise en scène pour
les metteurs en scène ces personnes sont
des sont des bonheurs absolu alors
Carmen ce sera vendredi au théâtre
montancier à 20h30 alors est-ce que
votre public a changé depuis 10 ans
est-ce qu'il a évolué il s'est enrichi
ouaisors trouve ton s enrichi parce que
bah 10 an c'est quand même long c'est
c'est quand même déjà une une grande un
grand bout de chemin comment mobilise
dès la première année en 2003 on a eu
des spectacles tout de grande grande
qualité et le public a répondu présent
mais c'est vrai que comme on le dit en
général c'est un peu le réseau qui
venait bon avec et puis petit à petit
ben les gens du montancier parce qu'il
faut savoir que la la direction ancienne
C gandaniel Laval et puis la direction
nouvelle maintenant depuis cette année
nous nous
a mis dans la programmation c'estàd que
on n'est pas à part on est dans la
programmation du Théâtre montancier ça
c'était une des conditions de force du
festival en 2003 ce qui fait que les
abonnés du du du montancier pouvaent
prendre des places aussi pour les
spectacles du ftival CE qui est toujours
le cas fa un public mixte c'est ça donc
on on a eu assez vite un public mixte et
et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui tous les publics viennent à
ORF les bon les scolaires aussi on en
parlera peut-être tout à l'heure alors
bah si justement les scolaires
parlons-en tout de suite parce que vous
proposez aussi dans dans dans votre
programmation 2013 un répertoire un
petit peu plus classique notamment avec
George Dandin de Molière donc une
adaptation de Molière qui sera présenté
par les les comédiens du Théâtre
eurridis alors eurridis vous les
connaissez bien ces comédiens alors vous
allez nous dire qui sont-ils mais juste
pour Rael pour nos téléspectateurs vous
étiez directeur de du théâtre ridis vous
avez laissé la main l'année dernière
voilà et alors racontez-nous ces
comédiens qui sont-ils bah écoutez bah
ces comédiens oui comme vous dit que je
connais bien puisque j'ai travaillé
pendant des années avec eux j'ai fait
multiples mes en scène donc l'année
dernière on avait fini avec eux avec le
les exercices de style de
Keno depuis de 2 3 ans on travaille avec
Richard leurt qui m'a donc succédé à qui
j'ai proposé ma succession eurridis et
qu'il l'a accepté avec pour ma plus
grande joie parce que c'est quelqu'un de
de très bon et puis de je crois de très
investi dans dans le projet maintenant
et donc voilà c'est sa deuxième mise en
scène avec les les comédien de ridis il
avait monté le pergunt de hipsen alors
juste est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler rapidement parce qu'on on est
un peu pris par le temps qui sont ces
comédiens al ce sont des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui enfin catalogué puisque on a
fait des des cases on met toujours les
personnes handicapées dans les cases
dans dans le style handicap psychique
voilà donc plutôt des gens qui ont des
troubles psychologiques plus ou moins
graves plus ou moins stabilisés avec
souvent des des des facteurs de
dépression mais voilà relativement qu'on
arrive relativement à stabiliser et qui
leur permettent voilà d'avoir choisi de
venir à Euridis pour soit faire des
décors des costumes et cetera là en
l'occurrence il y a les comédiens et
donc de de de créer de et ce sont tous
des comédiens professionnels hein ils
sont professionnels dans le sens où un
esad d'abord puisque c'est le statut de
base de de ridis un établissement de
service d'Aide par le Travail tous les
personnes qui travaillent dans amnésat
c'est à caractère professionnel ils sont
salariés à des conditions prévues par la
loi mais ils sont salariés et là il se
trouve que c'est un un un AAT parti
particulier puisque c'est un
éat orienté sur le théâtre avec
construction de décor costumes enfin la
petite comédie française du handicap
j'ai envie de dire avec un peu d'humour
et et donc voilà et alors une des choses
qu'il faut dire autour de ridis c'est
que en 2011 et donc pour l'année 2012 le
Conseil général nous a nous a récompensé
de tous nos efforts depuis de 25 ans en
en faisant de ridis un Centre d'Action
Culturelle
officiellement c'est une grande
reconnaissance c'est un één même très
important alors Michel Renau passons
tout de suite à la dernière date qui
clôture le festival et qui est important
parce que ça marque également un un une
avancée du du festival puisqu'il
s'élargit désormais à six théâtres
partenaires et dont notamment cette date
exceptionnelle au Centre Georges
Pompidou le 29 octobre alors vraiment en
deux mots qui va qui va se présenter
pour cette dernière soirée c'est flic
flac danza c'est une c'est une compagnie
de danse espagnole qu'on connaît bien
c'est la troisème fois qu'on les
programme au festival he fait depuis
puisque c'est la 11e édition c'est le
10e anniversaire mais c'est la 11e
édition et on a c'est des grand
spectacle avec plus de 25 30 danseurs
ils me font même danser des enfants
parce que c'est à la fois un lieu
professionnel mais c'est un lieu de
formation donc il mêle des amateurs avec
des professionnels mais le spectacle est
d'une qualité d'unemiss ce sont des
danseurs don dont la moitié de la la
compagnie voilà la moitié de la
compagnie est est handicapé avec des
handicapés qui peuvent être des
handicapés psychiques des handicapés
physiques et des des des jeunes
trisomiques et ils nous ils nous
produisent à chaque fois des spectacles
absolument extraordinaires on a vu
quelques photos effectivement on a on
oublie presque le handicap on voit même
le je dirais que le fauteuil devient
presque un un accessoire quasiment oui
ben ils sont ils sont merveilleux parce
que voilà il y a une il y a une
vraiment alors je suis obligée de vous
couper parce qu'on est vraiment pris par
le temps je suis désolé Michel Ren alors
toutes les dates sont à retrouver on on
pourra en reparler effectivement toutes
les dates sont à retrouver sur le site
internet donc le bandeau s affiché
puisquil y a neuf spectacles vraiment
une programmation riche je vous remercie
d'être d'êtreevenenu maintenant autre
festival nous passons au festival tout
mêlé alors Vincent amoureux vous êtes
président donc de l'association tout
mêlé organisatrice donc du festival
c'est sa 12e édition alors j'ai envie de
vous dire festival ték est à Mo comment
comment on fait perdurer un festival
pendant pendant 12 ans quelle est la clé
quelle est la recette la clé je sais pas
si réement une clé mais en tout cas
c'est bah l'éclectisme des des
programmes qu'on propose c'est euh c'est
effectivement aussi bah le le côté
convivial qu'on qu'on met en avant alors
c'est 3 jours de
festivité si j'ai bien compris vous êtes
sous chapitau c'est super ça pour le
temps comme ça qu'il fasse beau ou pas
et bien dans tous les cas le festival
couvert il y a pas de souci
effectivement comme ça les personnes qui
étaient réticentes à venir si le temps
le Perm ta pas là peuvent le faire alors
c'est une ambiance familiale puisque le
fait que ce soit éclectique finalement
votre public est assez large et ça
permet de mê un peu les gens justement
tout à fait les gens et puis les les
formes de culture aussi le fait qu'on
qu'on propose effectivement bah toutes
sortte de forme d'art que ce soit du
théâtre de rue de la musique des
expositions ou
effectivement tout ce qui peut se
présenter que qu'on arrive à dénicher
alors moi je vous propose c'est qu'on
regarde une petite compilation de
quelquesuns des groupes qui se
produiront pendant ces 3
jours is un CRS
méloman quand j'entends ces slogans de
cortège monocord des sans
armes j'ai envie de coller mes
arpèges donnez-moi un gros lar bien
flasque pour me servir de contrebasse
que ma matraque joue de l'arché sur un
gros qui peut pas
sauver
faccio le M
car
Lisa bélenjon vous êtes membre du bureau
de l'association tout mêlé également
bénévole alors comme on a pu le voir la
programmation plutôt éclictique chanson
rock électro alors la particularité
aussi de de ce festival c'est que ce
sont les bénévoles qui font la
programmation alors comment ça s'est
passé tout à fait ben en fait on est une
quinzaine à l'année et toute la
programmation est réfléchie et décidée
associativement on a quelques conseils
extérieur de programmateur professionnel
du réseau du cri un réseau des Yvelines
de musique actuelle mais sinon toutes
les décisions sont prises ensemble en
fonction de ce qu'on voit dans l'année
ce qu'on déniche ce qu'on a envie de
programmer pour faire découvrir au
public donc c'est vos coups de cœur
qu'on va pouvoir trouver pendant 3 jours
alors on invite pareil les
téléspectateurs à se rendre sur votre
site internet pour trouver l'intégralité
euh de la programmation on vous souhaite
un très bon festival ça démarre pour
rappel euh demain soir demain soir
exactement le but aussi c'est
qu'effectivement les tarifs soit
attractif donc effectivement c'est une
vingtaine d'euros pour le passe vendredi
et samedi par exemple et je crois 15 €
en tarif normal pour chaque jour voilà
avec des tarifs réduit en plus ok merci
beaucoup de votre participation à tous
les trois
merci on passe euh à notre chronique
cinéma pardon nous passons maintenant à
la chronique de Nicolas Gervet qui est
allé rencontrer certains des artistes du
spectacle Bobby laapinte repiqué de quoi
s'agit-il on
l'écouteberber Presque Oui evveline
galet ou encore Dimé ils ont tous uni
leurs talents pour reprendre à leur
manière des chansons de Bobby la pointe
dans le spectacle Bobby la pointe
repiqué présenté notamment le 28
septembre au SC carabé à La Verrière un
spectacle à la pointe de la
chanson
pas
que pas
drôle dan la pointe moi je suis
directrice du festival princial Bob la
pointe festival de chanson et avec mar
qui est directrice du du festival
Chantons sous les pains dans les Landes
nous sommes à l'origine de ce spectacle
et moi je suis Dimoné je fais la guitare
et je chante comme nous tous comme tour
à tour nous tous dans dans ce spectacle
récital rich esquimau m'a dit j'ai BO
une maladie de peau j'ai pleinigle sur
l'épaule je voulais en mourir maiston à
fait rire les plus tristes GIR même les
GIR les plus Moll
en 2012 c'était les 90 ans de la
naissance de Bobby la pointe et les 40
ans de sa disparition donc on a eu envie
de lui rendre un hommage particulier et
donc d'associer nos deux festival amis
pour faire une jolie création et un joli
spectacle hommage à Bob la pointe Marcel
n'est pas ce qu'on appelle un
intellectuel Marcel Marcel quand je
l'appelle moi je l'appelle Marcel il
répond pas mais il approche de sa
démarche gauche et l'on peut voir dans
son regard comme une lueur
d'intelligence il sait de quoi j'ai
envie il n'est pas si bête il sait que
c'est de son vie
record d'athlète je pose ma main sur son
beau bras que Mar riveil ça faitil qu'il
me suure ce curieux repr
tiens voilà du
boudin on savait qu'on avait envie de
choisir des artistes qui ont un univers
éloigné de celui de Bobby la pointe et
qui réinterprète totalement ses chansons
on voulait pas faire un aè hommage à la
façon de il y a eu une mise en
quarantaine une une marinade qu'on a
fait dans les Landes où chacun sur le
répertoire de B très petit sur une
carrière avec un écho énorme avoir 53
chansons c'est vraiment rien du tout et
dans cette dans ce répertoire là les 5
les 6 que nous étions au début
maintenant les les 9 il s'est avéré que
comme un vestiaire chacun on est allé
vers un Bob qui nous ressemblien on est
allé vers notre Bob à nous je
disourmeamour comprend
pe C n'est qu'un manuel elle connaissent
rien il a par que ses main qui font des
choses bien d'ailleurs moi j'ai pas le
temps de savoir qui est Marcel car mon
Marcel il me harcèle Marcel me harcèle
Marcel me harcèle c'est comme s'il avait
de vie il a plusieurs facettes
évidemment qui sont la drolllerie même
si c'est en permanence lié à
l'humour la mort l'amour le cul même on
va dire le sexe nos univers propres sont
tellement différents
que il fallait aller très vite pour se
rencontrer pour se respecter et puis
pour être irrévérencieux aussi envers
Bobby la pointe qui était quand même
quelqu'un qui était atypique qui était
un peu subversif qui était un peu que
Pon à mon à mon avis qui était un peu
anticonformiste qui avait cette cet
endroit là donc le fait que l'on passe
du temps à travailler ensemble on on a
surtout appris à s'apprécier et puis à
et accompagner la proposition de l'autre
sans la
jugerivre je suis ici que j'ai mal pays
je va
dans j'ai assisté à la Résidence c'est
vraiment avec avec grand plaisir que
j'ai vu se construire les
choses j'étais très touché de du travail
qui a été fait de l'interprétation qui a
été donné je trouve que ça donne une
vision vraiment différente c'est
modernisé évidemment ça ça donne une
autre écoute aux chansons depuis le
temps que je t'attends depuis le temps
qui est une chanson faite par Anne
Sylvestre chantée par Roland Bourbon et
Eveline galet quand on a Eveline galet
qui chante le premier couplet qui prend
la voix d'un Sylvestre on a quelque
chose de puissant sérieux et on a un
Rolan Bourbon qui ne change rien mais à
le voir tout d'un coup il nous donne
quelque chose de pas sérieux donc ça
crée un chemin assez troublant ça devait
être que deux concerts au début un dans
chaque festival ça aurait été très très
bien et puis voilà ce qui séduit c'est
évidemment cette idée de bonne humeur
c'est transmissible quoi une jolie MST
quoi
et voilà Bobby la pointe repiqué c'est
donc le 28 septembre au scarabé pour
l'ouverture de saison Aelia c'est à vous
merci Nicolas à la semaine prochaine
pour de nouvelles investigations passons
tout de suite à la chronique cinéphile
nous sommes mercredi c'est donc l'heure
des sorties ciné au micro d'é lodim
moine j'ai beaucoup aimé cette bonne
leçon sur l'hypocrisie des gens les
acteurs sont très très bien et c'est une
belle histoire très bon j'ai bien aimé
oui très divertissant ça prend ça prend
son temps et c'est ça c'est bien réparti
dans son rythme très très bien r C'est
Peach Black 2 en fait voilà c'est la
même histoire voilà ça se regarder pour
les amateurs de vinisel et de ridic
franchement je le recommanderais pas il
fait un espèce de petit mélange entre le
de et le premier qui était Peach black
je crois et c'est vraiment pas bon là
c'est pas forcément moi j'aime mieux les
films peut-être un peu plus optimistes
mais c'est quand même une forme
d'intimité c'est donc c'est c'est des
paysans et à la fois c'est ce qu'on
demande au cinéma d'ê
dépaysé la chronique cinéphile c'est
aussi l'occasion d'entendre un
professionnel du cinéma nous donner son
coup de cœur cette semaine c'est au tour
de Gael Pino responsable du cinéma Le
Grenier à Sel à trpe
c'est un débat euh autour du film Les
Moissons du futur c'est un documentaire
de Marie Monique Robin on la connaît
puisqu'elle avait fait le monde selon
Monsanto surtout dont on a beaucoup
entendu parler c'est un documentaire sur
l'agroécologie parce qu'elle a entendu
dans une émission que sans les
pesticides et et sans l'agriculture
intensive d'aujourd'hui on arriverait
jamais à rien et du coup le monde était
fini et à côté de ça il y a un
rapporteur des aux Nations Unies Olivier
de chuter qui dit dit l'inverse qui dit
que avec si on continue comme ça avec
autant de pesticides l'agriculture
intensive là on va dans le mur et donc
qui croire à la fin du nocument TER nous
allons parler avec trois intervenants
génération future des AMAP et de
l'association CTIN en transition nous
allons parler des enjeux de
l'agroécologie c'est une c'est un débat
organisé avec tdal qui est une
association cquantinoise qui porte des
projets éthiques et
solidaire notre édition est à présent
terminée merci de nous avoir suivi sur
tvifil je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine mercredi 18h30 à
bientôt